I play the game today against Ezra
chambers bit younger feel a master he
represents Burundi which like before
maybe a week ago I didn't realize was a
country I was to ask him if he's from
there but I know he's living in the US
and we had an interesting fight today so
I think what I'll do I'll go through the
game and I'll also share there's a video
on YouTube I did an interview with
Lenderman where I go through the game as
well but I'm making this mainly for its
twitch and for eventually for my own
YouTube channel yeah
there's me oh but people can't see me
but maybe now people can see me and we
discussed the game he asked me some
interesting questions
so anyway okay so we're gonna go through
the game I was black I knew he was gonna
play e4 but I didn't really know what to
expect beyond that he went for a Spanish
which is one of the lines I was
expecting I was doing some preparation
and four Knights like he's had a game in
the past where he's played h3 so I was
preparing h3 I was preparing all this
sorts all these like different moves but
he played Spanish so main line stuff and
I just I mean I knew I was gonna be a
fight tonight I had a feeling it was not
going to be determined in the opening
and he played d3 this was kind of the
first surprise of the game the main line
or at least the most popular line is
castling and then I would play Bishop e7
and yadda-yadda so I play b5 wait is
there oh there's this eye tracker wait
how did I enable that what I meant to
keep that off for a little bit
did I did I get rid of it I think I got
rid of it
there's this toggle key
I made cue the toggle key so I probably
press Q at some point yeah I got one of
one of these but we'll save it for later
do some puzzle rush maybe there's just
some tactics or some bullets but let's
focus on this so Bishop b3 also I was
curious can i play Bishop c5 immediately
just no use opening book as Bishop c5 is
playable because takes takes Knight
takes e5 not possible because tactics
Oh d6 is more popular but b5 okay so a
few playable moves here b5 Bishop to b3
and then I played Bishop to c5 I think
this is one of the main another kind of
advantage for black compared to main
line is because white is slower to do
this my bishop is a bit more free to
develop without getting kicked
immediately whoa gifting subs what does
this name so no Fanny gifting 20 subs
thanks so much I'll read them off
afterwards or shall I read them off now
maybe I'll just read them off now this
will take hopefully less than 20 seconds
starting now
tiny Dorfman Malina chasis of us keen
super Nangal 2 2 1 well the cookbook
table Florida Alex 1808 to construed mr.
Markovski Ark 0 I will check I mean
mystery chess crash 0 7 0 3
so right now see great header corrector
cron 999 probably 20 fungal and Missa to
blue auto pop and Joe Bruni
welcome everyone thanks so much love him
anyway back to the game I'm planning to
put this on YouTube for the YouTube
audience like I know there's always like
these comments like he that I look too
much at the twitch chats and not enough
at the game I apologize to people
watching this in the future this is why
you should watch the live on Twitch so
much action in the chat right now
bouquet will focus on the game Bishop c5
so this is a position I had like some
familiarity with so let's check the
theory I actually haven't checked the
theory in this position looks like we
followed some variation and some good
company here handful of strong players
alternate law stockfish for now I play
d6
he played c3 ok so main game is Carlson
Geary good company that I played rook b8
after the game Eastside rook b8 seemed a
bit weird or a bit it seemed he said
he's he felt like he should punish it
because it feels like a waste of time
but I played rook b8 because I wanted to
take and then after Bishop takes I
wanted to play this and I can't allow my
rook to be a target so okay so I'm
threatening to take he castled and now I
didn't take right away so if I take
right away and then like d4 comes and my
king still in the center so we both
castled and he played h3 h3 is very
patient I mean he wants to stop Bishop
g4 and then very soon he wants to play
d4 and then I think this was a critical
moment where I wasn't entirely sure what
to do and I chose probably the most
concrete approach there are a few
candidate moves I was considering this
and this abyss but the the main
consideration is taking on d5 I had to
calculate because after taking on d5
takes a 97 d4 white got some initiative
I'd have to trade off and then it was a
tricky position to evaluate so I end up
calculating takes takes 97 d4 takes
takes and then Bishop e7 and I figured
that it was at the very least
interesting and that's what we got
so take sticks
my e7d for take 6 Bishop e7 I felt like
it was a bit wrong because I'm leaving
my Kings side like lust offended like my
knight is really the only defender and
White has ideas of a queen g4 Queen h5 I
mentioned all all of this in the
Lenderman interview also ideas of Bishop
c2 and it seems like whites should have
more attacking resources than I have
defensive resources but I went for this
because there's a media question about
d5 and also I do have defensive
resources which include Knight g6 and
Queen f6 well I thought that was enough
to be okay so he played the move here I
think it was a little bit too passive he
played Knight e - 90 - made me quite
happy especially how like the game
unfolded we were analyzing after the
game some interesting line Queen g4
threatening Bishop takes h6 I was
fighting to play Knight g6 here like
maybe Queen C it would be a safer option
but after Knight she's sick sardine ie 6
and then things get really confusing
after I mean I have to take it takes I
could win this pawn humans this pawn I
have Queen f6 not sure how to evaluate
this I don't know if these pawns are
good or bad
but certainly interesting probably still
a three result game but we didn't go for
that or he didn't go for that I mean he
played 92 defending the pawn and like at
first when I saw this I thought this was
reasonable maybe preparing that f4 but
then the more I look to that the more
comfortable I I felt was Knight g6
and now I'm discouraging any piece from
coming to at 4 also ideas of Queen h4 or
Queen f6 you play as Bishop c2 and now
Queen h4 and not at all scared of takes
I mean this is pure happiness for black
so Queen h4 this is where yeah this is
where my pieces start coordinating there
there ends up being a lot of pressure on
whites and very quickly White's position
just crumbled played b3 maybe some logic
like pairing like the hard thing was it
was not easy to develop the bishop the
bishop really can't access any of these
squares Bishop d2 is passive thank you
is trying Bishop b2 and someday c4 I
just kept improving now when I play
rookie eights I have a tactical threats
the queen is now overworked and I'm not
sure how wide should defend lunderman
was suggesting before Bishop b3 but this
feels a little wrong I mean I have work
e5 here and then just preparing the
double-up so going to the game after two
rookie aides
he played queen d3 and i just go ahead
and take the pawn now there's there's
something to calculate here cuz after it
takes takes white could take on g6 I
assumed there were multiple ways for
black to be better here I was assuming
this should just be winning like I'm
temporarily down a piece but I have
massive attack against the king of
threatening discoveries mmm
I mean the bishop can't really develop I
mean I'm threatening like this and then
I was calculating some funny line
actually he takes takes here here here
and Queenie one with idea that if he
goes back it's it's me this is very
puzzle rush like
and then if he goes forward it's very
entertaining Queen here kingi for rookie
oh he is king d3 this was my calculation
during the game like I stopped at rookie
eights and it's probably just mating if
here this is mate so it's a funny
calculation I assume like at any point
like if I run out of checks for some
reason I have c6 and then I'll take the
bishop and just be winning so yeah he
didn't go for that so V if he goes for
this and Bishop takes g6 doesn't work
I'm still hitting the bishop an f2 so
you went for Knight g3 I played rookie 5
as a nice configuration like
everything's defended and everything's
like applying pressure - and there's
ideas like if the bishop develops to be
- I have Brooke g5 and there's a lot of
pressure on on g3 so I think like
already this is probably just crushing
for her black he played a four rook e8
just improving takes takes now this B
pawn is a bit poisonous if he takes it
but I just take on g3 because of the pin
it takes my bishop I meet so he played
Bishop d2 and I was thinking around here
it still takes a bit of work because I
didn't see any like immediately crushing
move but I was really pleased with the
move that I found here because it it
allowed me to create a threat which was
hard to stop it also had some trick to
it move I play this Bishop to c6 which
is actually somewhat multi-purpose I do
protect the pawn but more importantly
I'm preparing worth d5 it's a nice sort
of clearance move and the Queen is is
very short on squares and then on top of
that when I play Bishop c6 I was
thinking the most natural move
is Rookie one actually either up to you
one let's say rook fe1 and then there's
a nice nice
tactical idea here also Japanese tutor
thanks for a raiding party of 16 welcome
everyone
if you're just joining I am doing game
review I'm currently in the midst of an
over the war tournament it's a st. Louis
norm Congress we're just over halfway
through today it was rounds four and
five tomorrow will be rounds six and
seven going over my round for game of
today and this is actually a good moment
for the chat to think actually let me
know more bits let me play two more
moves I'm gonna give you guys the first
twos in the calculation thanks for the
bits Nicola Stillson
yeah the first two moves are actually
quite intuitive just takes takes takes
takes and I'll block to move in this
position find a tactic leave it up to
the chats a few people have it ear
Aikido and extreme dota both finding
Bishop takes you to very very nice move
and this was something to something I
calculated when I played Bishop c6i I
realized this was a potential trap that
I could fall into idea after King takes
you to it's just a simple fork night and
if White's
thought there is some move for white oh
yeah if I plays a Knight f5 I can just
take on h3 and trade Queens be up a
couple pawns so he played king h2 which
I was not entirely expecting thinking
about King you it does get off this
diagonal but it doesn't deal with rook
d5 and then it was just a matter of
keeping initiative and then simplifying
so Rick d5 Queen f3
it's still a little bit tricky I mean I
want to take the bishop
but then Queen takes c6 hits my rook so
I sacked the Queen with 95 and I thought
this is a funny configuration like minor
pieces very much in the center it's very
strange to have a rook like smack in the
center in the middle game but it's doing
its job required some lifting the Queen
only has a few squares move to to f5
threatening some check but I checked
first Knight g4 unleashing the rook
pieces were nicely coordinated pawns
pins had to take my Knights and then we
just simplify and like I want I'm up a
pawn because I won the d5 pawn and now
attacking the bishop in the other pawn
there was one last trick he plays rook a
to and now like originally I wanted to
take on f2 but whenever you like you
have a good position you always have to
be aware of your opponent's tactics in
this position a white can come back with
Bishop h7 check and that would not be
something I'd want to deal with so I
take with the rook that way my bishop
supports it takes takes played Knight f5
and then that was a matter of
simplifying the g6 gives away a pawn
temporarily but wins it back there's no
way to defend g5 and yeah he just
resigned in this position two bishops
up two pawns active rook so tough finish
for whites but I mean from my
perspective I feel like it was a pretty
smooth game I mean he he was clearly
more prepared in the opening but I mean
we got some position and I was somehow
able to emerge better I'm not entirely
sure where he went wrong I have a
feeling 92 was maybe the wrong approach
in this position maybe there's there's a
better move or maybe even earlier like
instead of h3 to do something else
anyway um I think I'll wrap it up there
at least for analysis of this game so
for the YouTube audience hope you guys
enjoyed that if you have questions feel
free to comment below smash the
subscribe button and all I'll see you in
the next video